vous avez écouté quoi j'ai twitté voter
marine le pen officielle au second tour
n'est pas donné un blanc seing c'est
juste dire non à l'extrémisme l'extrême
mépris l'extrême pauvreté dans laquelle
va nous plonger à quinquennat macron
l'extrême copinage d'extrême onction de
la france c'est entrer dans un train
alors mais twitter est pas être moi
c'est tout sauf macron eux
expliquez-nous
pour une raison que j'ai exposé
mon sort d'un quinquennat macron cas
était il faut être honnête dévastateur
alors je comprends que monsieur valls
puisse pas de l'entendre puisqu'ils
n'étaient pas là donc forcément juger un
quinquennat facebook serait plus bas
c'est vrai le fait est que vous étiez à
barcelone et moi aussi probablement que
j'aurais apprécié le cac à la macro en
tout cas je leur ai moins détesté si
j'avais pas eu l subir si vous voulez
dès lors effectivement mois le tout sauf
macron il est très clair il n'est pas un
blanc seing donné marine le pen dans la
mesure où si jean luc mélenchon avait
été élu avait été en tout cas est ton
second tour quoi vous auriez j'aurais
également dit la même chose aujourd'hui
si vous voulez très clairement on peut
pas se permettre le luxe d'un
quinquennat qui va mettre les français
dans la rue parce que nous sommes dans
un gouvernement qui a été le
gouvernement du mépris qui a été le
gouvernement des petites phrases qui a
été le gouvernement moi j'aurais aimé
pouvoir à dire écoutez j'aurais aimé
d'abord ne pas faire ce tweet en disant
bon emmanuel macron a été ce qu'il est
il a pris conscience d'un certain nombre
de d'erreur ainsi commise et peut-être
de ligne franchie dans le mépris en fait
des français on fait quand même deux on
est quand même en plein scandale
mckinsey ça interroge d'ailleurs ça
interroge le point de savoir si au
moment où emmanuel macron était ministre
d'économie sous le gouvernement de
monsieur valls mckinsey étaient déjà
présents dans le gouvernement nous avons
laissé les clés si vous voulez du
gouvernement français un cabinet de
conseil condamné aux états unis pour des
faits d'une extrême gravité c'est un
scandale qui a valu moins que ça a valu
la campagne mais la foire à châtillon en
2010 est donc les apl ont été réformés
par un cabinet de conseil vous avez vous
êtes rendu compte que dans ce
quinquennat vous n'aviez finalement
qu'un quinquennat du copinage et du
mépris que tout ce qui a été décidé la
et et les classes moyennes se sont
appauvris des classes populaires se sont
appauvris
les jaunes on a eu une répression sans
égal les vagues les non-vaccinés qu'ils
font emmerder mais attention il a dit
maintenant chaleureusement ou
amicalement at il dit donc maintenant
avec à présent avec la public en merde
amicalement une partie de la population
lui je vous emmerde avec alain on
peut emmerder amicalement quand on est
président on devrais pas dire ça
certains manuels valls ursa il a raison
fabrice di vizio je crois qu'il est en
train de faire la campagne des manuels
macron parce que vous avez dit tout à
l'heure pour l'autre débat tout ce qui
est exagéré tout ce qui est ce qui m'a
lâché silencieux valse de toutous inc
mais tout le cabinet de conseil mckinsey
est exagéré préval bleus le ton le dire
que vous étiez en france et 5 en mai
mais non excusez-moi monsieur valls
grèce mais effectivement je suis pas
bonne et moi mais ces gars là tentant de
ne m'être excusé moi
bien que quand même vous venez soutenir
un candidat nous avaient fui en partant
à l'étranger c'est quand même singulier
de venir défendre le bilan de quelqu'un
sous lequel vous n'avez pas voulu rester